Oh funniest was so Stevie blue-eyes is
with us and maliks friend is with us I
don't give his name way he's not the
great cardboard guy good comic but he's
in the room he goes hey man because
Steve was talking about how much money
his girl making is girls though number
one porno star in the world Aniston you
saw how much they make kind of only fans
that come so you know he's throw around
numbers next day our friend goes hey
Stevie I was talking to my girl man and
you know we're seeing about doing that
only fans think that's how much you guys
bring on I go well you know these girls
like the porn star that's one of the
reasons it's not gonna sing for
astronomers like cuz they don't like my
cos Stevie has a great dick but any was
any day
yes any any dick what word yes but she's
generous enough to give Stevie a cut
here's all we're seeing dog oh yeah your
girl's back let me see out there which
may make he shows it's a video and Molly
got the joke but it was Jesus she's let
me just describe it she's got a bowl cut
she's a rather heavy said Chinese
heavyset Asian woman it's all good hey
Chinese
pigtails with a prison tats here isn't a
two guys Jess and I go and I go all damn
I know you do so you're gonna make no
money if you show this but we can do is
just her feet if you do a feet jacking
off Molly hugs choke we're here laughing
motto hard as he goes used as you think
man I'll do just feet though don't show
the face nothing else he does yeah you
right you right we emits a good idea
Moloch and Steve were laughing so funny
no it was yeah it was pretty crazy he
wasn't aware of how the porn works you
can't just use your girl or that his
girls Dora Explorer through instance
there are there were issues there's a
there's a market for everyone but that
Nicole tends to be the big money she's a
superstar yes she is yeah she's the
Super's is racecar driving a [ __ ]
skill or a sport or both it's nowhere
near is grueling is boxing or MMA or you
know maybe even tennis or golf or
something it's not it's it's not
physically demanding what it does is it
it it's physically sort of commanding it
commands your attention no that's so and
you
don't realize what a weird calorie burn
your attention is like you don't realize
you turn your attention on and off all
the time so you kind of go like let me
check a text or what's that on CNN and
then you turn it off and then you come
back on and then you turn it off and so
like when you're boxing or playing
football or something like that's like
you got your attention and then there's
a moment where you go okay we go back to
a huddle yeah like I don't have to be
this is a weird full-time this is two
hours of pure attention it's two hours
of races yeah this this was a 40 lap
race it was probably in the car about
two hours so it's just full attention
this intensity for two hours so which
what ends up happening is you get out of
the car
and you haven't moved put your fire
shooters like sweat you sweat all the
way through because you're you're bolted
in in the six-way harness and you're not
lifting anything or doing anything it's
just crazy
well mathematicians and scientists and
Einstein talked about this like you when
you are thinking about a problem over a
prolonged period of time you actually
burn calories you you you you your brain
uses a lot of energy ah yeah Aikido and
all gluten free I'm like Einstein I'm
sure didn't have AB Einstein in college
I thought not good no no no there's not
a lot of well well there you go
surprisingly there's a penny of matures
with his sure
I'm so hot I think we fine I didn't
think we'd find him one holy [ __ ] that's
a Betsy he's a thicket he's in the thick
boy Michael Adam Ti is Kenny do you want
to talk about so easy you know we talked
about Piven and you talk about these
athletes and celebrities that had hair
transplant have you ever seen his he had
a hair transplant Oh Bob luck dude
no talked about the best of all time I
don't think yet oh here oh hello
yeah Wow those cornrows now what are we
doing how the [ __ ] did he get that love
cornrows a hundred million dollars a
year they gonna figure get his hair I
want to know I want to get some of that
[ __ ] she's like crazy you spend your
entire career wearing a full-face helmet
really we have to worry that much about
your hair yeah like he's a Tommy
Hilfiger model boy he looks a lot better
with you have a career where soon as the
helmet comes off somebody puts a hat on
some European petrol company that goes
on your head like there's not a lot of
scalp time yeah these guys you're right
yeah other time was both your bosses say
I'm impressed with this [ __ ] go that
one way it's a cornrows that's him
that's him now what the [ __ ] probably
you did I'd love to be him well I'd love
to get a nose ring but I can't pull that
off I'd love to have a hand tattoo this
guy's got it all down to a science who's
this style warning a timely story this
morning I helped my my girl has a
thousand dollar bed she she bought two
months ago and she's got she needs to
she's got too many [ __ ] beds don't
ask why so the guy she works with wanted
the bed frame brand-new he puts it in
his truck puts it we helped him get it
right in this truck frame and everything
beautiful bed Dawa I looked at I was
like I want this bed cool well he's
gonna drive down a Long Beach promise he
didn't he didn't and it was in the back
of a truck like that bear got to it it
went flying up in the 405's and
dangerous and I [ __ ] a semi mattress
and lanes yep need science dude and it
hit it but no one's that hey [ __ ] I the
suit and the mattress heavy it's all
throwing people with no one with the
problem at is this thick it's very
dangerous because it's this thick so if
you hit that
I know I might hit one I just buy this
on the highway and I almost [ __ ]
crashed no you or him or like yeah you
don't think we should may put a bail
like I left I thought because they were
mover guys there so I thought the guys
are doing like hey mover guys somebody
tie this down now
it'll be fine you know you do that
you're like I'm not going for her it
turns out mover guys are just you know
what we did not rattlesnake you little
snake snakes no didn't almost bite me
but I scared you don't but got scared
did well let me see this they're back I
would see you in a while I'm scared I'm
so scared
is that a robber oh yeah you didn't hear
it rattling I'm fine it's not fun
that's not now that now go back now
that's not easy
uphill sir no it's not no I need love
Jackie advice bike for that are you
using an electric bike on that yeah I'm
using the it's definitely so hard it's
very easy because that's not like your
normal electric bike that's got to do a
lot of work now I would be the best bike
ride is alright it's the best bike I saw
this oh this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah oh okay
this was sent in from many underscore
1987 on Instagram this has been
circulating where a woman asked this
construction worker if she could take a
photo with his screwdriver
yeah his power drill and she wanted the
photo to look like she was helping these
companies board up this happened
actually on Third Street Promenade here
in Santa Monica
somebody had this video of her and they
posted it online originally no one could
really tell who it was because she had a
face covering but when they got on to
Twitter people realized that woman looks
familiar they found out she was a
journalist she was an intern at the
Washington Post I believes for lost
rajala yes yes watch the video real
quick very pretty yeah
yeah
we get her boyfriend if I could see
where she asked her to wait but she look
like she was yeah but she looks like she
was gone defender B nope she did nothing
know enough she looks like she's
pretending to board up a store yes yes
like she's absolutely like doing work
out here on Third Street guys matter you
don't say yeah yeah it's pretty terrible
yeah her man
I liked it social media exposes phonies
mm-hmm goddang yeah that was very weird
and they got their lot her license plate
as well I wonder how many people
actually do that I'm sure a lot of
people actually do that too
I'm sure and then paint retweeted what
is wrong with these entitle [ __ ] who
the [ __ ] are you and who are your
parents you horrible person how can you
defend this so so um can I ask this 24
million views what what did what did she
say when she posted it I didn't see her
Instagram account actually went private
very quickly after this video went up so
a lot of people don't know if she ended
up posting it or not and people don't
know what she said if she did post it so
maybe she didn't post it and she was
just home I found out before yeah I
don't know is this is this what was she
doing was she just doing it to be silly
I don't think so she doesn't look like a
senator
that's not I'm asking you I don't
understand what what stupid question
though but this is someone trying to
gain the Graham do it for the grant like
you said yeah we know if she posted or
not we don't she went private very good
it because the the video went out I know
but we're assuming we she did to post it
well why else would you do it though I'm
just a maybe like hey look I'm boarding
something up to her friend or something
I don't know like I'm you sweet no but I
I mean you'll it's done you're sweet no
I I'm a little confused about it that's
all it's pretty easy to figure out be at
least social media account after mmhmm
yeah
yeah I'm hilarious
anyway um what's next general mover guys
like it won't be met words gonna think
of anything I've never had never moved
my house when somebody didn't steal
something from me really in the case
I've lost two guns a shotgun and a
[ __ ] pistol like I move your gun I
lost art work everything I didn't they
maybe I did no no it was I move the gun
they're coming stuff when they're coming
in they're coming out and somebody picks
something up so my girl my girl was
talking to people and we were talking
about Houston and um and and my friend
said Frank said how did Brendan do and
she goes she goes well he was only on
for 20 minutes but he was great it was a
great 20 minutes and she just said it to
him not not I was talking oh and I went
I went I said did you just say it was a
great 20 minutes because yeah yeah he
killed and I went that's such a
milestone it's so hard to have a great
20 minutes yeah it's so it how many
people do you know how long does it take
and when somebody says that in an
offhand manner and I texted him I said
hey congrats that's a [ __ ] and I
watched it I mean I said to his brother
I go he's [ __ ] he is such a real comic
now he said I like him killing it and
it's probably 25 minutes you know and
and I'm out tonight and now I did write
it all for him people think that O'Brien
and Rogen just write the joke is you're
gonna write about my mic's actually
Emily in my kid yeah actually if
anything I would always try to give him
notes and I would write and he would he
would he go you can't do that I can't
yeah yeah if I can't I got to figure it
out he would even want tags because it
was too much for him yeah cuz he was
like that then now it's you and it's
gotta be me yeah it's like and also
seeing you at the store you know you
never shied away from any any shows that
you would show up and whether it's a
belly room show main room like whatever
like you show up and it was is it is
dope to see the six damn bad
had bad ba-baby at the rehab rehab for
what for childhood trauma and also
prescription pills she's like 717 but I
mean imagine what she's going through
right now she's well with reality stars
to where they don't know that they're
gonna be so famous overnight that they
don't know how to deal with that instant
fame so they're trying to numb it
she kept yeah really really really fast
like overnight when she went on dr. Phil
mm-hmm and she was painted as the
villain too so that doesn't really help
anything and call it a lot of hate
imagine the world hating you're at 13
just overnight be tough let's stop
that'd be really yeah it's [ __ ]
really I don't think people are meant to
be famous I agree especially now it's so
sad be like there's like you know like
Tom Cruise famous is it was it the plan
we're not done our DNA to deal with that
although like I seem about George I
don't know why I'm not George Clooney on
my bike ride this morning well that's
what I'm saying like I sing at George
Koon he got some stuff going on and so
in reference George Clooney and then I
was thinking of them I'm like he's not
social media he moved to Italy he
doesn't deal with any anything I'm he's
so famous we can't go anywhere no can't
you can't do anything humans aren't
weren't meant to be this shot in depth
on the height of his fame moved to a
small town in southern France I would
[ __ ] solve that she'll DiCaprio man
it's like you can't know who wants to be
a [ __ ] la father think will think
well you can't go anywhere like that
like if you want to get coffee you shut
down the coffee store you can stop to
get gas and people you know what I deal
with on a daily basis enough why me my
[ __ ] me where's my mark you know what
I found your demo is when we went to
Vegas to do a show together and the
drives do 40 hell up to me and then
these old like oh my gold Birds Brandon
just next card of a ladies built like
girls that hey soos lights would come up
to
Mellor it wasn't a it wasn't a this is
taking these 30 times while talking to
you why wouldn't I give that to you as
it's a guess it's a gift it's a gift